c'était la meilleure des mamans
un jour un taonique est venu la voir il
a ouvert ta chemise et puis il avait la
photo de maman qui était
comment tatouer sur sa tête
la France à chaque instant et le
charmant pays des surprises dans cette
paisible petite bourgade dévot joue au
bord de la Moselle on s'attendrait dans
ce beau dimanche de printemps avoir
inauguré la statue d'un général d'un
Amiral ou d'un savant pas du tout la
foule de temps les Vosges vient célébrer
son héroïne Clémentine de lait la femme
à barbe
[Musique]
mère de Thaon-les-Vosges et heureux de
vous dire quelques mots bravo Monsieur
le Maire
alors
monsieur le député Monsieur le Maire mes
chers collègues mesdames messieurs dans
les Vosges par la voie de sommaire vous
souhaitez ce matin un bon dimanche et
vous remercie d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui
l'exposition de Madame delé la femme à
barbe de Thaon-les-Vosges l'exposition
la plus souriante et la plus amusante de
France une exposition comme une en
existe aucune autre dans aucun pays du
monde Clémentine de lait notre
compatriote n'était pas une vulgaire
femme de foire c'était si j'ose dire une
femme comme les autres mais une femme
avec une barbe n'avait pas seulement une
grande barbe elle avait été aussi un
grand cœur et était juste et normal
qu'une exposition lui rendit hommage
alors merci d'être venu merci de venir
nous rendre visite vive la Lorraine
vivent dans les Vosges et bravo à la
faveur
[Musique]
[Rires]
de cette marche qui a servi dans
d'autres circonstances plus notoire la
foule vient à admirer
sa femme à barbe c'est elle Clémentine
delé fier enfant de la Lorraine
boulangère et cafetière citoyenne fêté
pendant toute sa vie une telle pensée
qu'elle aurait un jour son musée et
pourtant elle l'a son musée avec tous
ses souvenirs avec tous ces portraits
des portraits qui rappellent à ceux qui
l'ont connu les êtres qu'elle aimait
dans son enfance dans sa jeunesse et son
élégance
son mari le boulanger Joseph aimé ta
caresser la barbe de clémentine ah la
douce barbe soyeuse
Clémentine l'avait laissé poussé à la
suite d'un pari et cette barbe était
devenue son ami sa compagne elle les met
autant que ses chiens mugett céleste et
Valentine et le public du musée
regardait merveilleux Clémentine dans sa
petite voiture
Clémentine à bicyclette une des
premières vélocipédies de
Thaon-les-Vosges la première daronnaise
qui monte en avion et la seule tahonesse
qui entra dans la cage aux lions il
paraît qu'en la voyant les lions eurent
très peur
et le public admire aussi la lettre
officielle de monsieur Émile Combes le
petit père Combes qui autorisa
officiellement
Clémentine de lait à s'habiller en homme
la décision fut prise en 1904 en même
temps que la loi sur les congrégations
mais clémentines continuent à vivre
simplement entouré de sa famille de ses
amis jusqu'au jour son impression pour
lui permettre de faire le tour du monde
lui remit son passeport
signe particulier porte la barbe et
prend donc la foulée merveilleux évoque
ses souvenirs et l’époque où Clémentine
faisait admirer dans le monde entier une
barbe qui vient de France les officiels
dont Monsieur offert député des Vosges
répondent courtoisement aux interviews
monsieur offert est-ce que dans votre
jeunesse vous avez eu l'occasion de voir
la femme à
barbein je dois dire qu'effectivement
j'ai bien connu madame delay c'était
autour des années 25-26 vous voyez que
ce n'est pas dire mais j'ai quand même
eu le plaisir de boire de la bière
servie par Madame delay et je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait tellement de
parlementaires de par le monde où en
France qui puisse avoir vu le même
honneur le seul député français qui a vu
la femme à barbe et bien je vous
remercie j'aperçois monsieur grossier
monsieur grossesse
91 ans tous mes compliments alors
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez elle se
détailler la barbe tous les convient à
peu près vous la voyez tous les mois à
peu près et au moustaches
pour voir et bien je vois ça me va vous
apporter chance ah madame Leclerc ça
doit vous rappeler des souvenirs
votre maman avec les hommes en tout cas
c'était la meilleure des mamans c'est
vrai je crois qu'il était très aimé
votre moment
un jour un taonique est venu la voir il
lui a apporté une friture il pouvait
votre maman m'a rendu beaucoup de
services je l'aimais bien alors
il m'a ouvert sa chemisier et puis il
avait la photo de maman qui était
comment tatoué sur sa tête
c'est sur ces genoux confirmant
s'asseyait pour caresser la barbe de sa
maman
cependant dans toute la ville du
Thaon-les-Vosges les commerçant avait
décoré leur vitrine pour célébrer la
femme à barbe et de magasins en magasin
c'était à chaque pas une surprise
le café de Madame Dolet a disparu mais
les anciens la boîte encore solides à
son comptoir servant elle-même la goutte
au citadins et les souvenirs vont bon
train écoutez-les dans les cafés
d'aujourd'hui
il paraît que le meilleur moyen bien
souvent de la faire venir au café c'est
peut-être prendre un verre éducation
inverse
sortait le client là il y a pas de
problème
c'est ici dans le charmant village de
Chaumousey qu'en 1865 naquit la femme à
barbe à quelques kilomètres Maurice
Barrès est né à charme il avait juste
trois ans de plus que Clémentine gueuler
peut-être l'a-t-il rencontré une petite
paysanne Lorraine au pied de la colline
aspiré
mais la foule au musée admire maintenant
la galerie des compagnes de clémentine
delet les deux plus anciennes femmes à
bord du monde signalait dès le 15e
siècle dans la chronique de Nuremberg en
Barbara la musicienne de 733
celle que vous allez voir on l'avait
surnommé
la petite chèvre pétulante oui elle sent
toute la pour les amateurs de pilosisme
et direcutisme Madame Deley pleine de
santé aurait été heureuse de vous avoir
dans son musée venir à elle tous ces
petits-enfants qu'elle adorent une jeune
étudiante des Beaux-Arts de Nancy
monicarnold lui a déjà consacré à un
ravissant ouvrage vraiment original mais
toute épices écolières de
Thaon-les-Vosges avait tenu le jour de
l'inauguration à montrer de quelle façon
elle se représentait la femme à barbe
Clémentine delay qui était si fière de
sa barbe qu'elle conserva pieusement
jusqu'à son dernier souffle comme elle
serait fière aujourd'hui mais terminons
par un sondage d'opinion publique
écoutez
Gérard est-ce que tu as vu la femme à
barbe
est-ce que ça t'a plu cette dame avec
cette grande barbe comment tu as trouvé
ça tu as trouvé ça jolie ou vilain
vilain vilain donc quand tu te marieras
tu n'aimerais pas avoir une femme qui a
une grande barbe comme ça
et tu aimerais mieux avoir une femme qui
sera habillée avec une robe ou avec un
pantalon
habillé avec une robe et bien voilà en
effet la jeunesse française ils veulent
bien voir un musée avec une femme à
barbe mais ils veulent pas caresser la
barbe de leur femme
[Musique]